Salut.
Ça y est on l'a fait.
On vient de passer les 400 000.
C'est juste un truc de ouf 400 000.
Vous êtes 400 000 sur cette chaine.
Merci, pour commencer !
Il y a un an, quasiment jour pour jour,
on était en train de préparer la F.A.Q.
des 2 500 abonnés...
Pour fêter ces 400 000...
j'ai décidé de vous appeler.
C'est à dire qu'en préparation de cette vidéo,
il y a quelque temps sur Facebook,
je vous ai proposé, si vous étiez disponibles,
de faire une petite mentalisation via Skype.
Plus de 2 000 réponses plus tard,
et bien c'est parti, c'est ce matin que je vais vous appeler pour essayer de vous mentaliser.
On verra le nombre de fois où je réussi
et surtout, à la fin de la vidéo, je vous explique quelle a été ma méthodologie pour vous mentaliser.
Merci d'être ici.
Et moi je vous met 400 000 pouces  en l'air !
BAM !
[Musique Générique]
[Contact Skype] : Salut.
[Fabien] : Tu es le premier que j’appelle
sur cette série de vidéo. T'as vu ?
[C.S.] : Ah, bah génial !
[Fab] : Alors sauf que tu ne sais pas du tout
pourquoi j'appelle.  C'est ça ?
[C.S.] : Et non, je ne sais pas.
[Fab] : L'idée, pour la vidéo des 400 000,
c'est de... c'est d'essayer de trouver
à quoi pense une personne parmi un choix limité,
sur un maximum de personnes, et à la fin de la vidéo
je vous expliquerai comment j'ai fait.
Je t'entends, mais je ne te vois pas Carla !
[Fab] : Donc tu choisis une des 8 images.
Celle qui te fait plaisir à toi.
[Fab] : Tu en choisi une, dans ta tête.
Tu regardes  les 8 dessins
et t'en choisis 1 dans ta tête,
celui qui te plait et tu me dis
quand tu es prête.
Donc tu choisis 1 images parmi les 8 images
et tu me dis "ok. Je suis prêt."
[Fab] : Et en fait, moi je vais te poser 2 à 3 questions.
[C.S.] Ok.
[Fab] : Tu n'y réponds que dans ta tête.
[C.S.] Hmm... bah c'est bon !
[C.S.] : C'est bon !
[Fab] Tu ne dois jamais me répondre verbalement.
Ça marche ?
[Fab] Par exemple dans les images,
elles se différencient vraiment par deux types :
il y a celles qui ont des courbes
et celles qui n'en n'ont pas.
Je vais te demander de regarder la tienne
et juste de regarder, dans ta tête,
s'il y a des courbes ou pas
dans ton dessin.
[Fab] Ok.
Merci pour cette réponse non verbale.
C'est, euh...
est-ce qu'il y a des courbes dans ce dessin?
Tu vois dans, parce que suivant les dessins,
il y a des dessins qui sont plutôt linéaires
et des dessins plutôt avec des courbes.
Et vu comment tu as regardé par 3 fois,
je dirais que oui, c'est courbé de partout.
Donc ça c'est chouette !
Euh par exemple le Om,
il est complètement ouvert
et des dessins qui sont fermés.
Genre le carré. Tu vois ?
Il est complètement fermé.
Du coup si c'est plus ouvert, c'est
soit sur les vagues, soit sur le Om.
Et si je me plante complètement,
c'est sur le cercle ou le cerveau,
Et je pense avoir ton symbole.
Il y a des images qui nécessitent
4 traits pour être dessinés,
et d'autres qui en nécessitent 3 ou moins.
Tu vois, par exemple, le carré c'est 4 traits,
l'étoile c'est 5 traits,
pi c'est 3 traits,
la croix c'est 2 traits etc, etc.
C'est une mini-mentalisation des familles !
[C.S] Voilà.
[Fab] Une très rapide.
Je vais au culot, si je rate je rate,
et je garde quand même le rush.
[Fab] Je mettrai dans la vidéo que j'ai raté.
[C.S.]Ok.
[Fab] : On va voir mon pourcentage.
Est-ce que tu peux me dire exactement
à quel dessin tu pensais ?
[C.S.] Au signe Pi.
[Fab] Au signe Pi !
[Fab] Ouiii !
[C.S.] Ouais !
[Fab] On est bon !
Merci monsieur Maxime !
[Fab] ...plusieurs indices,
et quand je fais ça, ça marche bien,
du coup, je dirais que
tu es sur le cercle !
[C.S.] Aaahhh [Rires]
[Fab] C'est bon ? C'est ça ?
[C.S.] Oui !
[Fab]: Et du coup, je dirais que
tu es sur les 3 vagues comme ça,
C'est ça ?
[C.S. un peu "dépité"] Ouais.
[Fab] Ouiii !
[C.S. Riant] Oh, c'est trop facile...
[Fab] Je dirais... Pour l'instant,
j'ai fait un sans faute depuis ce matin,
mais là.... J'ai un petit doute
sur toi... Je dirais que c'est le Om.
L'espèce de symbole comme un 3
avec une vague derrière.
[C.S.] Ouais, c'est ça.
[Fab] C'est ça  !?
[Fab] Ouii !  Je te checke par l'écran,
mais je te checke, meuf.
[Fab]Je pense être certain d'une chose :
je pense que tu as choisi quelque chose avec
des lignes très droites, euh...
Mais j'hésite entre l'étoile et Pi...
Et je dirais que tu as choisi
le symbole de Pi.
Est-ce que j'ai bon ou pas ?
[C.S.] Oui.
[Fab] Ouiiii !
[Fabien fait claquer ses doigts]
J'ai eu chaud !
A 90% sûr, tu as choisi le cercle.
Est-ce que c'est correct ?
[C.S.] Non.
[Fab] Aaah ! Zut !
[Rires]
Tu es mon premier fail de la journée.
C'était quoi ?
[C.S.] Le Om.
[Fab] Ah, le Om. J'étais bon sur les arrondis,
mais c'était ouvert...
Ah pu****, je me suis...
[Rires de la correspondante]
[Fab] Écoute, je suis désolé pour toi.
Ce n'est pas la connexion,
c'est juste moi qui me suis planté.
[Fab] T'es le premier fail.
[C.S. Hachuré] Mais, t'av... ust... on...
[Fab] Hein ?
[C.S.] Tu avais presque bon, c'était euh...
[Fab - Riant] C'est trop adorable.
[Fab] Et j'ai l'impression que tu étais
sur le symbole du Om.
[Fab] C'est bon ou pas ?
[C.S.] C'est... une sorte de 3 avec euh...
[Fab] Exactement. Je vais te le dessiner
tout de suite...
C'est...
C'est cette espèce de truc,
là, comme ça.
[C.S.] Ouais, ouais, c'est ça.
[Fab] C'est ça ?! Ouiii !
On s'arrête à sept appels, parce que la période
que j'ai, là, pour tourner est terminée.
J'ai beau eu refaire les tirages au sort,
j'ai à peu près 40 demandes de... de...
de messages où je n'ai pas de réponse...
Alors que j'ai demandé à tout le monde
si vous êtiez disponibles.
Et le pire c'est Julien Hodier, Gaëtan Ronner,
Maxime Bouvier, Etienne Laroui, Thomas Jacquin,
Mathieu Machessa. En fait c'est que les mecs
qui ne me répondent pas...
Du coup, je vais avoir une vidéo
qu'avec des meufs,
et on va se dire :
ouais... comme par hasard !
Merci en tout cas à tous ceux
qui ont participé.
C'est cool.
Et pour la méthode que j'ai utilisée,
je vous l'explique :
J'ai créé un effet tunnel sur 8 images.
Ces 8 images là.
Je sais qu'en trois questions,
je peux trouver quelle image a sélectionnée la personne.
La première question c'est : est-ce que le dessin
a des courbes ou uniquement des traits droits ?
Et si vous regardez bien, il y a 4 dessins
avec des courbes et 4 dessins avec des traits droits.
Une fois que je sais cette information. Soit verbalement,
soit, en l'occurence pour la vidéo, non verbalement,
je vais encore re-diviser en deux.
Par exemple, s'il y a des courbes,
je vais essayer de savoir si le dessin est fermé
comme le cercle par exemple.
Ou ouvert, comme le Om.
S'il y a juste des traits droits,
je vais essayer de savoir s'il y a 4 traits
ou moins que 4 traits.
Par exemple, dans Pi il y a 3 traits,
mais dans le carré il y a 4 traits.
Et là, encore une fois, il ne me reste
plus que 2 possibilités :
c'est à dire que, sur mes 8 de départ,
j'arrive, pour ma dernière question
à un choix final entre :
soit Om et les vagues,
soit le cercle ou le cerveau,
soit la croix ou Pi,
soit l'étoile ou le carré.
Et c'est un vrai truc, là, que je vous donne,
pour vous entraîner à faire du mentalisme,
vous pouvez reprendre exactement
mes dessins,
et vous vous entraînez.
Et à chaque fois vous faites valider ça
verbalement, par la personne.
Vous dites, par exemple :
Ah, ben je pense que tu es sur une courbe.
Comme ça, si elle dit non, vous pouvez
toujours vous rattraper et continuer,
si elle dit oui,
ça vous permet d'avancer.
Et vous savez qu'en 3 questions
vous aurez le dessin au final.
C'est un excellent entraînement.
J'espère que ce petit cadeau des
400 000 abonnés vous plaira.
Merci tellement d'être là !
Moi, je viens vous voir bientôt.
Sur les dates de tournée.
C'est un vrai kiffe de vous voir
chaque fois, à la fin.
Là je vais être en spectacle
à Grenoble,
après je vais être en spectacle
à Lyon
Rouen, Nice et peut-être...
Je dis bien : Peut-être...
Je suis en train d'essayer de faire
un événement à Nantes,
Pour réunir : les Bretons qui voudront
bien faire le déplacement
et la zone Nantaise
même ceux de Charente-Maritime qui
voudraient venir...
Donc, on est en train de voir ça.
Dites moi d'ailleurs, dans les commentaires
si vous seriez capable de vous déplacer à Nantes
pour venir. Auquel cas, je prendrais peut-être
le risque d'organiser cet événement.
Quoiqu'il en soit : merci d'être 400 000.
Merci. C'est énorme.
C'est Ouf ! C'est...
Pour une fois, c'est moi qui vous mets
le pouce en l'air.
A très bientôt.
Ciao.
[Musique Générique de fin]